gary how are we doing man so i have a
daughter
that's 22 years old she is
homeless she lives in her car
she's addicted to methamphetamine
um she has two children
that were taken from her about six or
seven months ago
uh recently learned that she's been
using drugs since she was 14. um
in 2016 uh her mother
my wife of 26 years uh passed away from
cancer and for the past or for the last
or for the next two years
you know i tried you know to do
everything i could to
to help you know my daughter including
you know getting her into counseling
paying for her rent her utilities i
bought her a car
paid her bills um
you know because i wanted her you know
to get on her feet
you know after two years
nothing worked i i i felt like the the
poster child of uh the enabling parent
so you know the last two years
you know she's really just gone uh
downhill um in the last couple weeks
uh received a phone call from her where
she
sounds like she is ready to accept
responsibility
you know she obviously is struggling
and she's talking about uh wanting to
to get into rehab and
the first thing that you know came to my
mind was
um what is the right amount of help
you know what i don't want to do is get
back in this enabling you know
cycle where i am preventing or keeping
her
or giving her an excuse why not to
you know move forward with uh
rehabilitation
um you know so what's the right amount
what's too much
you know i've obviously struggled with
you know
setting proper boundaries you know in
the past
and of course telling your nose
difficult for me i
you know i i think i'm i'm i'm a fixer
by nature but i can tell you that
this is beyond my ability you know
to help so dude one
as the father of a daughter i can't
think of a
more gnarly awful place to be than where
you are
and just want to acknowledge straight up
that sucks that's hard and
that's that's that is the depth of hell
for a parent and i hate that for you
um i also cannot put my head
i've sat with countless people in this
situation
i i can't put my head around somebody i
can't put my head around a situation
where i would have to come home
and my wife has passed away and so
you're dealing with trauma on top of
trauma and
i want to start all this call by letting
you know you've mentioned a couple of
times in this call
about how you're not doing things right
and you've mentioned a couple times in
this call
that you kind of taken ownership for
your daughter's choices and her
decisions
and i want you to be graceful to gary
okay
yes you're owning a lot of this and
um right wrong or indifferent your
daughter's made some decisions and some
choices
that you've got to let go of for a
season okay
if one day you're you are in a place
where she's well and you're well and
y'all want to go
get a therapist together and go
spelunking i wouldn't recommend that but
you can
at this point i want everything in your
life to be about moving forward
you've done the best you can with the
tools you had because you love your
daughter more than life itself
right is that fair it's very true
okay so the rest of it is cinder blocks
that you are carrying around every day
and all that does is weigh you down at
work that weighs you down in your
relationships and more importantly it
doesn't fully let you connect with your
daughter
okay and so put that stuff down and and
then i want to commend you man most
parents don't ever make it to the point
where you are
which is i've got somebody who's hurting
i'm just going to keep
dumping money and resources and heart
and soul and mind and all this stuff
into a giant black hole
and you've said i can't keep doing that
i'm causing more
harm i'm causing my self-harm and i'm
not doing
the good that i want to be doing what i
do next so dude high five to you man
um it's a hard place to be so tell me
about this phone call you got
she says i'm ready and something in her
voice if
for those of you listening if you've
ever dealt with somebody who struggles
with methamphetamine
it is a it's just evil in its purest
form
it takes everything from you it takes
your soul from you it takes all of your
ethics and morals and character just
takes everything you have from you and
um
loving somebody who's caught up in in
meth is
is almost like loving somebody with
alzheimer's they just
they're a shell of themselves and that
you want so badly to believe that
they're still there and they're not
they're a ghost and so gary it
matters a lot to me that you as her dad
got a call and suddenly you
feel that bell rang it ringing for the
first time in a long time what was it
about that call that
reconnected you to so
she said that she was stressed out she
said that she knew that she did it to
herself
uh she said that you know she was going
into a uh trying to get into a shelter
uh at the time and this was a couple
weeks ago that she she was saying that
you know she had a flat tire she didn't
have any gas she hadn't eaten
that she's tired and she travels from
hotel parking lot to hotel parking lot
to
to get their wi-fi so she can
you know communicate on the
internet or make phone calls
she said she didn't know how she got
like this she said she was disgusted
with herself
okay and uh and
and i never heard that from her before
it was always the excuses
and everybody else that is the problem
and
and you know the reason she was there
you know she was the victim and um so
this was
uh good to hear that
she was indicating that she was ready
you know to take something
ability so when it comes to enabling
here's my thoughts about enabling are
all over the place and they're usually
specific to a particular
individual situation not always we can
draw some some big broad brushes right
but often it's very human specific it's
just
situational right but most of the time
that boundary-free living comes from
exactly that not having boundaries not
being intentional not setting up who you
want
to be who you want your kids to be what
you are going to value with your money
right what you are going to be willing
to invest in what kind of life you're
going to be willing to invest in
and so all that comes to if
if i don't consider it enabling if you
decide i'm going to pay for
rehab if that's where you're going to go
i would not be in favor
of writing a nest
amphetamine addict who's lost their kids
right and that's when you start
realizing okay this is
this is over you some people won't stop
coming to family events and some people
will cuss you out via text message or
send
mean phone messages or whatever but it's
when you get into the
to the darkness right when you let your
kids go
when you're living in parking lots right
that's when you know that you
are you're out right and so when
somebody turns around and says
i can't do this i'm i'm at the bottom
and i need help
and then they look to you i'm not going
to ever give that person a penny
a dime i'm not going to write them a
check but if you have the financial
capability and you can help with
rehab and you can pay a rehab facility
direct
i don't see that as a as entitlement
i would also say a person who is a
current meth addict or even
early early stages recovery of any kind
of addiction
they're not in a place to make deals if
that makes sense
and so if you start putting stipulations
on this they're not gonna be able to
hear it
um they'll say yeah sure great because
they want to get to the next place
they're gonna feel hurt and abandoned
and abused if they violate these
agreements that you come up when they're
in the throes of addiction and
then you take your funding away so i'd
be clear
and not do any negotiating i would have
a clear strategy on your part and say
here's what i'm willing to do
um and but it's going to have to be an
inpatient thing and i want you to know
just as a dad who loves this baby girl
detoxing and getting off meth is brutal
and i would expect some starts and stops
and
i would also expect there to be some
great success on the back end
living into that optimism so what do you
think is too far
when it comes to enabling your daughter
well i i think what is too far is what i
started doing i i think with the best of
intention
was thinking that you know that i could
uh you know just completely financially
support her and then she would
you know uh do the right thing which you
know
um you know clearly she didn't
um you know uh so i
i i do uh i i've since remarried and
i've had conversations with
uh my wife about um
uh rehabilitation and and uh you know so
we're
we're certainly open to do whatever we
need to do
to be able to help uh my daughter
um you know my struggle you know as i
said was
you know um what is the right amount
you know what is uh what was too much i
mean even when
she called me uh when she was in the
hotel parking lot
uh i did my daughter my oldest daughter
and i
visited with her and we got her a couple
nights in
in a hotel uh we brought her some food i
fixed her flat tire
i put gas in her car and i gave her a
food
cart to a local restaurant so she could
get something to eat
and see though those things to me are a
dad who loves his daughter
right and i think going into it with the
heart
understanding that that is not going to
solve her problem but you do get
that's that's as much for her as it is
for you
right because i i don't know that i
could go to bed knowing that my daughter
is sleeping in a hotel parking lot
right and i know it's cool to talk tough
about boundaries and you just gotta draw
lines and all that
but i tell you what man if my daughter's
sleeping in a hotel parking lot i'm
gonna go get her
right and that's hard when you're
dealing with coke that's harder to deal
with math that's hard when you're
dealing with
you know when you're just pilled out
it's those things are hard right
and so buying a food card that she can
only use in one place they'll figure out
ways to sell it right we all know that
but
um if that becomes a routine at some
point you've got to draw that line and
they've got to make
adult decisions and it's hard hard hard
um
go ahead i was just going to say that
after i did
those things that day i walked away
wondering
if if if i made things worse
if i did too much and was she going to
you know delay sure and i didn't even
want her to delay a day
right well and that's where um you can
do some work on your end you can go
contact a local rehabilitation place
and you can get the information you do
not want to get information
through your daughter right because it's
going to come at a very
tilted angle and you want to get that
information from
from the the place get the cost get all
that get with your insurance company
and then you and your other daughter go
sit down and have a conversation and say
we want to go today
and we're gonna we're willing to take
you i'm gonna pay for it or i'm gonna
help you pay for it
um but we're gonna go today and that's
the way to set that up and if she
chooses not to that's when you say then
i'm gonna try again in 30 days
and what i don't want anyone to ever do
is give up on their kid but i there's a
difference between
supporting and giving up right and
you're gonna have to get somebody to
walk alongside you because dude brother
you're still carrying some of this
around
is that fair it is okay
and i did have a uh conversation with a
local
rehab today good um uh they
asked me to give my daughter uh their
phone number and name
uh to see if she would call them you
know to
you know do some screenings so i haven't
i haven't heard back from her so i don't
know if
she's done anything yet my guess is she
won't
right my guess is that um
you're gonna have to go sit pick her up
or meet with her for
um a meal or meet with her and to set up
an arrangement where y'all are going to
meet
and say you're going to take her and
again i know that we've got to put this
responsibility on
addicts if you've been if you've worked
alongside addicts for
a long time you'll understand their
their
ability to think rationally is different
than ours their their
brain has poison pulsing through it and
so to expect them i'm just going to wait
until the xyz
that sometimes works and sometimes is an
irrational response
they can't and so showing what
at the root of uh the root of addiction
is a connection issue
they are using drugs to cult to
wallpaper over this lack of connection
and this inability to
to hold somebody tight and to be held
tightly
and so all that to say is gary your
heart's in the right place
i wouldn't wait for her to call i'd set
that up and
some places may not take her because of
that and i would go pick her up and say
today's gonna be the day and if she gets
out of the car then she gets out of the
car
and you're gonna have to have a friend
that you can go sit with and cry with
and then you can give it a shot in 30
days and let her know
i'll be back in 30 days i'm your dad i'm
not going to give up on you i'm not
gonna keep putting gas in your car
um i'm not gonna keep paying for hotels
i'm not gonna keep giving you money
um that's that is enabling but when
you're ready
i'll drive you and drop you off and
because we've been blessed financially i
will help pay for it
and um that's a gift brother gary so
thank you so much for
um yeah thank you so much for
your heart man and let me know how that
conversation goes and i would love to
know
if she does man i would love to know if
she goes plugs it in that'd be great